i have to go have this finger x-rayed
elbow things and this hand kind of got
smashed but it was fun it was good it's
all
it's all in good fun she does a
wonderful fall which she's practiced
and uh you know she's a true pro and i
think she's very
convincing as someone playing her mother
i often go oh
i was thinking something simple
traditional
the flopper diver no way am i
oh my god oh she's cracked her head open
yes in fact she does try to trip me in
the next scene in revenge
um and it works she's entitled to that i
guess
it had to look real sweetheart you fall
lousy when you know it's coming i
fall fine fake
oh shut up
i'm a horrible liar so this has been a
this has been a good change for me
because i've had to
very quickly act like i'm a good liar i
never did i was a perfect teenager
mom i never lied ever i'm conning a lot
and lying a lot in this movie it's a lot
of fun well i don't
really like that term i would say
mother and daughter making their way in
a difficult world
no one else to look out for them and
that's how they want it one
horribly traumatic day in which my
client suffered irreparable
psychological damage to her self-esteem
oh and she keeps the mercedes well i
think being an actress is conning people
every single day i mean
truly because you have to make people
believe that you're something that
you're not i mean i'm counting people in
this movie hopefully
hopefully it'll turn out to be a good
con i mean you're always counting your
employer into giving you raise
my whole business is conning someone or
other into giving me a job
whether it's my agent or the producer or
the studio conning gets to be sort of
i haven't tried it off the set but it's
i'm learning a lot
so watch out restaurants of course your
meal is a complimentary
armand a bottle of wine quickly perhaps
a 69 merlot
you know these girls don't kid around
they really go for it big time with
their clothes
and it's it's it's lovely to see that in
a film of course we have very good
reasons it's our
you know our livelihood is at stake um
and i play
several different characters all who
have very different looks
and it's been great there are some very
unglamorous things our characters go
through
in very glamorous clothing i have to say
bejeweled
in the night we're dragging dead bodies
around things like that
so not hmm i am not dating the walking
dead
paige the older the better good luck
they died right after the wedding and
then you're talking widow money
she's a lovely girl she doesn't need any
watching over from me but it's
you know we play a mother and daughter
who are a little bit like that you know
with a lot of love you know they have a
routine
of i know it all and she knows it all
and you know i think you know all the
girls and i know what you did last
summer and i still know we're definitely
using
ripley as a role model um yeah yeah no i
was
i was a huge fan and you know
ghostbusters hello she was in the
coolest movie ever
love ghostbusters and um yeah no she's
she's amazing and incredibly talented
i've learned a lot so far
i don't know i've done so much of it i
sort of feel like just doing the very
ladylike stuff now
you